two people have been killed and more
missing after a landslide in Northern
Pakistan a highway west of his shower
near the town of torcum was hit Before
Dawn on Tuesday Al jazeera's Kama haidar
is joining us from Islamabad what can
you tell us about the situation in
Peshawar right now Kamal
well just to give you an idea the hyper
boss connects the city of peshawa to the
city of jalalabad in Afghanistan this is
a narrow pass and of course a lot of
trucks normally are stranded on those
roads because there is work going on at
the main border terminal which of course
forces all these trucks to be on the
roadside now what happened last night
there was a lightning and thunderstorm
which triggered a landslide and that
Landslide buried about 20 trucks with
containers on their backs some of the
drivers were preparing to start their
first in the month of Ramadan they were
cooking alongside those trucks and they
were the fire now the rescue efforts are
still underway that arterial linked to
Afghanistan which connects to a Kabul
and onwards they still block rescue
efforts are still underway and of course
ambulances and heavy equipment has been
employed in the area but they showed you
the vulnerability of the area this is a
an arid Zone it has no tree foliage
cover and to hold the ground so an
incident such as a lightning storm or a
thunderstorm or heavy downpours makes
this very vulnerable to landslides now
of course it will be important to see
whether there are more bodies found in
those trucks which are buried under a
huge pile of rubble this is of course
rocks and mud that came down right
smashing on the roadsides and as I
mentioned this is a narrow Corridor and
that of course makes everybody more
vulnerable because they have to park and
wait for several hours before they're
given a clear to approach the Border
thank you so much for that update from
islamabads